before we go here's one thing you can do
today to live a happier healthier and
more productive life it's thanks to our
partnership with Gretchen Rubin and her
award-winning podcast happier on podcast
a studies show about 20% of all
Americans are chronically late and
nearly 30% struggle to arrive at work on
time New York Times bestselling author
Gretchen Rubin is here with some tips to
help show you how to show up on time
good morning Gretchen this all starts
with getting out of the house on time
doesn't it right now one reason a lot of
people are late is they're trying to do
one more thing they want to finish that
email they want to put in a load of
laundry what you can do is you can move
your productivity to the other end you
can say okay when I get there I'm going
to review that document or figure out
that scheduling rather than trying to do
it before you leave a lot of people are
late because their kids are dragging
their feet put your shoes on where your
books you have your homework how do you
speed up your family's routine what you
can do is these are easier said than
done but one is to have the key place
for the keys the wallet the sunglasses
all that and also have everybody get
ready the night before get pick out your
outfit get your papers together get your
gym bag together have it ready by the
door because that can really speed up
your morning it doesn't apply to work
but isn't there a 15 minute grace period
where you can put the world according to
guys that's a New York City thing
regulate it was so crowded yes but
there's no such thing but what you can
really do is look at how long your
commute actually as we often have a
fantasy of how long our commute is or
how long it takes to get to school so
really time it out and so that you can
leave at the right time instead of
chronically being late and that because
that impacts other people that's what
you're like that we should think about
how it impacts other people right
because when you show up yeah everything
starts but when you're late people
resent it how do you trick yourself into
getting into a better schedule when it
comes to being on time well you can
change your alarm so you can have
somebody else move your alarm for you
yeah and also getting up early getting
up a little bit early so you can move a
little bit floor and that helps a lot of
psychology involved in this that we're
you know when we're late makes us
happier I want to know what we're doing
happier well part of it is like why are
you late some people really have a bad
idea of time they're not good at
engaging time so they might need several
reminders like now and then I'm have to
hit the snooze snooze snooze and some
people do they want to be they want to
get something done before
leave and they underestimate how long it
will take us to do something so we're
not always good at guessing yeah how
much time we need to accomplish the task
I like the tip of moving that task to
the other location yes all right
Gretchen Rubin good to see you on this
Monday morning good way to be here that
will do it for us we invite you to tune
in to CBS Evening News with Norah
O'Donnell that's tonight and we'll see
you tomorrow right here same time same
bat-channel
take it easy bye-bye